about five years ago a British TV show
called love don't judge featured a
glowing profile of five people uh one
woman and four men who were in a
polyamorous relationship with each other
and clips from the episode went viral
and the five love birds quickly became
the faces of polyamory and they
are interesting faces indeed
watch this is Tori she fell in love with
Travis
and
Ethan and
Mark and Chris their four-way
relationship is working wonders for them
the relationship could best be described
by having Tori as the Hub and all of us
are spokes on a giant wheel but not
everyone understands the dynamic I was
like oh you're kidding that you're
joking how will this poly relationship
cope with a further addition to the
family yes how will uh how will they all
cope with the new addition to the family
well unfortunately we got an answer to
that question rather quickly and the
answer is horrific only five weeks after
the baby was born baby you just heard
about there Ethan Balcom one of the five
Musketeers was arrested for abusing the
infant so viciously that she had severe
injuries to her ribs lungs limbs
internal organs and had several uh brain
bleeds as well now balcolm uh reportedly
told police that he he injured the baby
because he was frustrated that she was
preventing him from
sleeping so it turns out that the man
who volunteered to be a part of this
grotesque unstable and dysfunctional
polygamous relationship is also himself
a grotesque unstable and dysfunctional
person which should come as no surprise
but it would be a surprise to you if you
listen to the media which has been in
the midst of a full-court press over the
past few days to promote this kind of
dysfunction to the masses so first up
and this again is all in the past week
as we start off 2024 first up to the
play was the New York Times with an
article about according to the headline
A polyamorous mom who had a big sexual
adventure and found herself now this
polyamorous mom has apparently just
published a memoir titled more A Memoir
of open
marriage because needless to say what
the world needs most right now is yet
another Memoir written by a middle-aged
woman about how she embarked on a quest
of selfis Discovery and the quest
involved nothing but you know having sex
with a bunch of random dudes that's
exactly what we need right now uh you
know there's a memoir like this
published every 45 minutes or so and
they're all the same you know all of
these women are interchangeable their
experiences are as uninteresting as they
are unoriginal and their insights uh
what little insights they have are equal
parts cliched and bogus now next there
was a big piece in USA Today declaring
in its opening paragraph open
relationships are having a moment
polyamory ethical non- monogamy and
similar terms are becoming a bigger part
of our cultural lexicon but perhaps the
most known type of open relationship is
swinging and swingers are having a
moment too just ask Kylie George a
swinger who Chronicles her journey on
swing talk a hashtag with more than 2.6
billion views on Tik Tok the community
also connects via symbols an upside down
pineapple is the most viral and
well-known George recently married his
her uh her partner and the the pair were
able to celebrate with all of their
swing talk Creator friends and
communicate within a Discord group of
more than 30,000 members they plan
events educate provide resources and
enjoy a safe communal
space now you could have probably gone
your whole life and uh been happy not
knowing that something called swing talk
exists but now you know for better or
worse and that leads finally to New York
Magazine with its cover story for its
latest issue promising a practical guide
to polyam polyamory for quote the
Curious couple now before we read any of
the article in this issue of the
magazine we should note the cover of the
magazine which you could see right here
and you could see the words polyamory
and big bold block letters along with a
picture of four cats embracing and it
kind of makes you think why did they
choose cats for the cover photo I mean
there must have been some thought put
into this they must have
discussed this at some length like
what's the cover photo going to be for
this uh big big our big issue about
polyamory and they reviewed all the
possible options and decided to go with
cats which is an interesting choice
considering the more obvious choice
would be a photo of an actual
polyamorous couple I'm sure they could
find plenty of poly or not couple but
but plenty of polyamorous people who are
you know willing to pose for the picture
after all these people are not nearly as
camera shy as we all wish wish they were
but you could you could see why they
didn't go that route and and for one
thing you know polyamory represents
mating habits more often found in
animals than in humans by pushing this
on us they are pushing us to behave like
beasts and that could be the message
here but I think more likely they
realize that most polycules in real life
are a horror to behold you know we saw
what happened the last time they gave us
a face of polyamory and they don't want
to make that mistake again so they
they'd rather not show you the kinds of
people who are actually doing this um so
they show you cats instead anyway once
we move past the cats we're told the
story of a married couple named Nick and
Sarah um who have chosen the polygamous
lifestyle and here's what it says just
uh right to right off the bat quote non-
monogamy is really just designing the
bounds of what we want in our
relationship and what we're comfortable
with Nick says for Nick and Sarah the
relationship design looks like this Nick
and Sarah are married Sarah has had
multiple other committed relationships
while married to Nick currently Nick has
a girlfriend Anna who has a husband Alex
and Alex has other people with whom he
explores his desires the E easiest way
to explain all this might be in the love
language of most ethically non-
monogamous people Google Calendar Sarah
and Nick share a calendar Nick and Anna
share a calendar Alex and Anna share a
calendar Sarah and Anna do not share AAL
calendar but are aware of who has Nick's
time on any given day same for Nick and
Alex they are sah and Nick and Anna and
Alex a modern polycule living laughing
loving and doing a lot of therapy oh I
bet yes what a joy this must be you know
if you want a date night with your wife
um you have to put it in her Google
Calendar and hope she doesn't already
have plans with her boyfriend that day
like that's the idea here um now this
article in New York Magazine goes on and
on for thousands of words um the author
and the people she's interviewing are
under the impression that their story is
an epic fascinating Adventure in reality
it is again the same story uh all of
these people all these other polyamorous
groupings are telling it's the exact
same story Sarah the wife says stuff
like I was on a journey to reconnect
with my body and learn about myself as a
sexual being as we've seen women like
this you know they love to talk about
their sexual Dianes as a Journeys right
as if she's uh Frodo trekking across
Middle Earth you know to to destroy the
ring in Mordor and and not just a
middle-aged woman having sex with
different dudes and then we're told that
Nick uh the husband at first struggled
with the whole his wife has sex with
other guys thing if you can imagine you
know it was it was it was a little bit
hard at first um but Sarah helped him
very generously to work through these
feelings and at one point uh we're told
when Nick was feeling especially jealous
Sarah asked him how do you need to feel
loved by me which a pretty good question
for a wife to ask her husband or vice
versa the problem is that apparently
stop having sex with other guys was not
an acceptable answer to that
question and uh you know because why is
that well it's important that the
couples in open marriages or open
relationships support each other and
supporting each other always means in
their world bottling up your feelings
while your spouse has one Affair after
another um which is to say supporting
your spouse in this case means not being
a human it means not responding in a
human natural way to the fact that your
spouse is is serially
Unfaithful last year because of you
pre-born network of clinics saved over
58,000 babies and thanks to all who made
it possible let's cele by hearing
Dominique's story here it is I was just
kind of like Lord if this is you know if
this is the way you know let me know if
this is not the way Give Me A Sign you
know before I walk through these doors
and I was as I was getting ready to walk
up the steps and touch the door knob you
know a guardian angel and he just told
me he was like baby you don't have to go
in there and he was like I know someone
that can help you just to see the
development of a baby that small and I
say baby because I mean he had little
arms and legs and I mean you know it was
actually a human you know and to see
that and to have that physical and that
contact once you look at that I think it
just pulls on your heart each of these
babies are truly a miraculous and every
day pre-born celebrates 200 miracles for
just $28 a month you can sponsor an
ultrasound and help save a life when a
mother sees her baby on the ultrasound
hears his heartbeat that child's chance
of life is doubled so let's join
together and help mothers choose life
just style pound 250 and say the key
word baby that's pound 250 baby or visit
preborn dcomm mat that's preborn
docomo Amory Tik Tok account called
remodeled love and um in the video we
see uh what is apparently a husband
gushing over his wife's latest
boyfriend unfortunate choice of words
there perhaps but anyway watch what I
was just saying is that this man gets it
okay because you are a catch and he
makes an effort he puts intentionality
into his communication he comments on
your posts and your stuff he makes plans
he wants to be around he's proactive
he's got a great attitude just in
general and he's just a delight to be
around and you deserve someone and he's
pretty great lover apparently as well
so um these are all of the things that
you've been wanting and I was just I'm
just telling Stargazer here over text
that there's while you've had a lot of
great Partners there's always been
crucial pieces of intentionality missing
but this man gets it now if you if you
didn't know any better and you saw that
video you would think that this was uh
you know this was the woman's gay best
friend and not her husband and then when
you're told the context you realize that
your original assump
was still basically correct for all
intents and purposes now you may be
asking
yourself are any of these people
actually happy living this way because
again if you're a normal person and you
see all this and you hear all this you
think well that just sounds totally
miserable like that sounds it's like a
walking nightmare a waking nightmare
every single day who would want to live
this way um that polyamorous quintuple
that we talked about at the start of the
monologue they did their best to appear
happy
and then a few months later one of them
landed in jail for nearly beating the
woman's five-month-old child to death uh
the guy in that video we just played a
moment ago is trying his best to appear
happy and quote unquote supportive but
if you listen to these people speak for
longer than 20 seconds which is not an
easy task I admit you'll find that their
their deep profound unhappiness
eventually comes seeping through and
soon it's the only thing you can see
when you look at them so the facade of
Happiness lasts for about 20 seconds and
then if you listen for longer than that
all the rest of it is oh dear God we are
desperately
unhappy indeed even in these propaganda
pieces meant to promote polyamory still
the majority of the word count is
devoted to explaining how the
participants deal with their resentment
and jealousy so jealousy by their own
account is an everpresent feature of
their lives now that's not the case in a
healthy monogamous relationship okay in
a healthy monogamous marriage which is
to say a real marriage um jealousy
really shouldn't even come up if if you
trust your spouse your spouse is
faithful nothing to be jealous about um
but in these people's lives it's just
every single second of the day but they
have their ways of explaining that away
so back to the New York Magazine uh
article again briefly quote celebrating
your lover while they marry their
partner while supporting your lovers
lovers lover while they go through it uh
is an example of what Anna calls living
life on hard mode there's a real sense
of connection that I think comes from
doing hard things and I'm someone who
loves to do hard things Sarah explains
further um some people like to run
marathons we like to uh do some people
like to run marathons we like to do
polyamory complex relationship stuff
Sarah's favorite activity for the two of
us to do is couples therapy Nick says
smiling uh navigating the relationship
Dynamics is kind of generally a fun
thing for us uh it's it's like uh for
relationship
nerds
um you know there's a lot of different
puns you could make and Sarah talking
about she likes to do hard things but
you know we're not going to get into
that uh and and this is another tangent
I'm not going to get into right now
again but um here's more proof that uh
most therapists are completely useless I
mean these two are apparently seeing a
couple's therapist like
recreationally and and this couple's
therapist has we can giving them advice
that does not
include stop engaging in serial
adultery so they are a couple that is
constantly in a state of adultery and
they're going to a couple's
therapist and given the fact that they
keep going back to the therapist we can
assumed the therapist has never once
said to them you know one thing that can
make things better for you guys stop
having sex with people that are not each
other um but aside from the fact that
therapy is so often a scam what we see
here is the familiar attempt to paint
sin and failure and selfishness as
complexity you know their open marriage
is making them both miserable but that's
only because uh it's it's um hard you
know and it's hard in the same way that
running a marathon is hard they say and
the analogy is interesting because of
course running a marathon is exactly
what they are not doing okay A a
monogamous marriage can much more
accurately be compared to a marathon now
I don't really like that comparison
comparison because a marathon to me just
seems totally miserable from start to
finish which uh marriage is not but but
at least
marathons take commitment and
perseverance and those are the two
things that polyamorous people
absolutely avoid at all costs being
polyamorous isn't hard in the sense that
marathons are hard uh these kind of
relationships are hard in the sense that
it's hard to be a heroin addict you know
in the sense that it's hard to be a
pathological liar because you have to
keep up with all the
lies it's hard not because you're taking
on a challenge or you're doing doing
something difficult but worthwhile but
because you are a weak person following
your most Bas desires entirely unwilling
to control your urges or strive for
virtue that's the kind of hard we're
talking about you know uh your your life
is hard not because you're doing hard
things but because you refuse to do hard
things it is hard in the way that it's
hard to be weak not in the way that it's
hard to be strong those are very
different kinds of difficulty and the
difference is that there is no true
happiness there's no true Joy available
at the other end of the difficulties
that that you are experiencing as weak
and Unfaithful
people you know unlike if you are strong
and virtuous and trying to be committed
and faithful and a good spouse um you
know there's hardships and difficulties
that come in that sense in family life
but at the other end of it is immense
Joy whereas with this kind of hardship
and difficulty at the other end of it is
just more hardship and difficulty
um so a monogamous marriage which is to
say again a real marriage will have
hardship sure you're not going to be on
cloud n every moment of the day until
death do you part that's just not
reality but there is immense Joy
available to you if you both work for it
in the in the case of the non-
monogamous marriage the open
relationship which is to say the fake
marriage there's no joy ever available
the most you can hope for is momentary
pleasure which is something you could
have gotten in monogamy as well so
there's nothing you can get out of it
that's good that you couldn't have
gotten
uh with a real marriage there's a lots
of bad stuff that you will get out of it
that you would not have gotten out of it
had you had a real marriage um you know
in a real marriage and monogamous
marriage you could have had the pleasure
and the joy uh if you had had the
discipline and integrity to go get it so
there's no doubt that these non-
monogamous groupings are full of
absolutely miserable self-hating
jealousy riddled people trying to find a
way to be happy in an arrangement that
turns out nothing but Despair and
anxiety every single day that that's the
reality for the poor fools on the ground
who are trying to actually live like
this trying to live like beasts instead
of human beings like cats instead of
people and um by the way by focusing on
the unhappiness of the adults involved I
don't mean to suggest that their
suffering is the most dire side effect
or consequence of polyamory no I mean as
we saw at the top by far the worst thing
is the untold misery and Trauma and and
suffering uh and abuse and worse
suffered by the children who are brought
into and brought up in these chaotic
degenerate and dysfunctional
environments so as always children are
the real victims here but what about the
elites who are pushing
this I mean what do they get out of it
um why has the media you know jumped on
board the polyamory train all at once
with such coordination well because this
is the next step in the destruction of
the nuclear family some of us
conservatives not enough of us but some
of us uh predicted 10 years ago that
this is where it would all lead you know
after obera
fell there are some of us who said this
is what's happening next and it's
happening uh we said that the assault on
marriage would not simply end there it
would continue to the next destination
of course we were laughed at and we were
accused of engaging in a slippery slope
fallacy but as always it turned out that
the slope was as slippery as we said and
the only thing fallacious about it are
the arguments presented by the people
who are trying to expand the definition
of marriage into Oblivion so the that's
where the fallacy is but the slippery
slope is
real now don't give us too much credit
for being right though like it didn't
take a prophet or a genius to see this
coming the marital Union has two
essential Dimensions it is fundamentally
impr principle
procreative and it is monogamous and
committed um once they waged an assault
on one dimension it was only a matter of
time before they moved on to the next
and it really didn't even matter which
one they started with because because
the end result is the the same so
wherever it began we know where they
want it to end with the death of the
family which has always been the number
one enemy and the greatest of all
threats to the leftist elites who run
our country they cannot enact their
agenda and exercise total control over a
culture that is comprised of strong
loving individual family units where
children are raised by caring mothers
and protective fathers they they cannot
control if that's the way Society is set
up they are uh they
there's nothing they could do the Elites
for all their money and power would be
rendered nearly
impotent if that's the kind of society
we had which is why they have to tear
down the family and have been trying to
do so for for many decades and
tragically they have largely
succeeded they have succeeded anyway on
a general
level but I can tell you they have not
torn down my family and they never will
and hopefully they haven't torn down
yours either whatever you do don't let
them hey YouTube thanks for listening to
the show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there